we've got everything that we need on the
planet at this time but we just need to
be able to cooperate at scale creating
che truly decentralized peer to peer
distributed planetary operation system
the wealth disparity is the greatest
it's ever been in history and it's only
going to increase with automation until
we have a different set of systems that
actually create different incentives
competition still and scarcity and
really this planet has everything that
we need and we just don't have the right
infrastructure yet as I have allowed my
own feminine to flourish and to not be
shamed my masculine has actually gotten
even stronger and when I looked at
different religions and ancient
civilizations that there was a common
thread through many of them
[Music]
[Music]
boom what is up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
are on site in Woodside California with
an incredible team of humans building
the future we are talking to the new
earth planetary alliance we have amber
we have Christopher and we have Ben
what's up everyone hello hello hello yes
I'm super happy to have you all on the
show I'm really excited to unpack
planetary architecture the protocols we
need to build the future this is gonna
be a lot of fun so I like to I like to
usually start off by asking about you
know how you even got involved in
planetary architecture we'll have amber
tell us a little bit about that and then
we'll jump into what exactly planetary
architecture is what these protocols are
and how to best move forward so let's do
it you start us off yeah beautiful so
hmm it actually began like this mm-hmm
with my eyes closed and digging a little
deeper into that inner knowing and
exploring that a bit further and that
took me into understanding the laws of
vibration and frequency and light and
continuing to explore that further and
to what are known as the laws of
creation and how I began to understand
when I looked at different religions and
ancient civilizations that there was a
common thread through many of them and
there was many ancient practices that I
began to pick up and embody over the
years of my research and development
which lasted for about five and a half
years and the common threads that I
began to see were beginning to correlate
with the laws of creation and the
clarity that came through was that they
all tie in to the laws of creation and
they were just different lenses to look
at them through
and so that led me into astrophysics and
interstellar physics and understanding
the celestial harmonics of the universe
and how that works with our brainwave
frequencies as well as our
electromagnetic fields and how deeply
interconnected we are okay now what you
started unpacking there was this these
laws of nature the reality of existence
how we live what ancient civilizations
have known what we know now and how to
merge this this old nough swiss newness
and have these laws be really
practically implemented and enjoyed and
followed throughout our existence so
what are some of these ancient laws of
nature what are these laws yeah so we
have the the law of polarity the law of
vibration and when you begin to look at
these these laws and you really began to
look at the mechanics of how they work
you can truly see the the mechanics and
and your reality creation and let me see
here for a second if I can
so some laws of nature would be things
like the way that we perceive space-time
and the way that we perceive the DNA and
molecules and atoms is this part of the
laws yes absolutely that's that's the
deeper facet of the laws of creation
absolutely and then what are some of the
polarity and some of the other laws that
you were speaking of earlier maybe
unpack those a little bit for us yeah so
the law of magnetism which a lot of us
are you know those who don't quite
understand what the laws of creation are
you know many people see the polarity
and their life they see the magnetism
and their life of how they're magnetized
to certain people and
or also not magnetized to certain people
and projects and yeah I'd like to see if
I can pass over to christen and then I
want to hear from you too about the so
just you know what is it about new earth
planetary Alliance what is it about
these laws of nature what is it about
all this that you want to you know bring
to civilization just on a little bit of
a grander scale before we unpack more of
the nuance yeah I mean ultimately it's
about for each of us we're trying to
figure out life quote-unquote like we're
trying to be like oh I figured it out
and then I want to tell you about it
because I have a better life because I
figured it out and this is not at the
level of the personal this is at the
level of the collective its how do we
use these laws and the understandings
that we've come to to create a better
system for humanity to co-create and
actually build futures that we want to
live in - it's very well said yeah
and I think for me the law of polarity
is one of the most important that we're
all experiencing right now I think the
me - movement and so much of the rising
feminine energy that I think we all feel
is a response to a society that has been
incredibly out of balance and incredibly
polarized society and what the laws of
nature teach us are the ways to actually
come back into balance that it's when
these two forces actually merge into a
form of sacred Union that's when we can
actually really accelerate our
transformation and and when both are
able to play the unique role that
they're there to play hit the light in
the dark the male and the female we see
this not just in you know our
interpersonal dynamics but you know it's
it permeates all of existence so when we
bring ourselves back into alignment with
those two fundamental polarities then we
can really unleash the creative
potential
of humanity of the creative forces of
life itself yeah I like the way that you
two just made a very it was really well
put together but both of what you said
we had the the the polarity and the
re-equip reom of what needs to be is
making the co-creation to move forward I
like that a lot and so how about we talk
a bit about these you know new earth
planetary lines
we're wondering you know what exactly is
that we were talking a bit about you
know these protocols we're talking about
the way that we can actually do the
creation there are certain things that
you want to manifest in the different
communities to be able to do that and
you have these different accelerators as
well feminine intelligence so tell us
about start unpacking this for us yeah
so even going deeper into understanding
the laws of creation each law has
different principles that govern that
law and that's really where the make the
the deeper mechanics come in that we can
begin to create protocols for and
integrate them into our social
innovation technology development and
you know biological regeneration and
things like that so the principles
around these different laws of creation
when we look to them or really how how
nature works on this planet as well
which many of us are aware of that and
so when we look at the natural living
systems and how they work it's a very
graceful thriving system and when we
look at the feminine intelligence
energies and how we move through our
interactions with more of the feminine
intelligence qualities they actually
correlate with the living systems
principles and so we really feel that
that's that's what's missing and all
this exponential innovation
an attack we have so many incredible
minds it's mostly been men for many
years and we are starting to see many
incredible minds coming from you know
the the feminine intelligence side and
what we want to really bridge through at
this time is is weaving that it's not
just women weaving through the masculine
and feminine of of our individual selves
and really pulling that through so we
can begin to scale that level of
interaction throughout everything that
we do that was that was a good though it
was a good way to put us into a context
of there are certain social changes that
we want to bring about how exactly do we
do that and we started talking about the
feminine intelligence which is now
coming into an equilibrium with a
masculine intelligence and it's looking
to be extremely beautiful future of
co-creation now let's talk about
protocols yeah I'd actually like to
mention just a little bit more around
like what that actually looks like right
so you know and even for let's just put
everyone in the same field for a second
you know all men and all women that are
pioneering the way today we're seeing a
lot of masculine approach to drive
things forward to architect and engineer
to develop and let's let's do it and
we're running out of time and you know
there's also a lot of competition still
and scarcity and really this planet has
everything that we need and we just
don't have the right infrastructure yet
so once we have the infrastructure in
place with the right protocols in place
we can begin to open up those flows for
optimal potential and so what we're
seeing with the the more feminine
intelligence protocols is yes we still
want to drive exponential innovation but
we want to do it with with honoring
what's coming through and how do we
really honor what's
through when working with these feminine
intelligence protocols and and it looks
something like you know let's let's
design and architect an engineer but
let's also take time to reflect and be
with with the information that we're
receiving because a lot of times if you
are downloading lots of information and
you actually take the time to step away
from it you'll begin to receive more
clarity around what's coming through and
moving through around the co-operative
aspect is that we will be able to get so
much more done if we open up the
channels of communication and resources
and begin to rid redistribute this this
planetary wealth and not just meaning
currency but wealth and throughout you
know all aspects yeah so this so well
said the abundance that is already here
and that the frameworks are just not
designed well enough to foster the full
potential of what humanity can unleash I
love that I was so good and then I also
really liked what you said because we
now know I've talked about this enough
that I've come back from my fourth
10-day meditation retreat and when you
go offline for 10 days and you go inward
for 10 days you would it just it
connects so much of what you're building
in new ways that you've never thought of
before and so it is so crucial to take
time away from building and go inward
and reflect ok
now let's let's as we talk as we started
doing some PT PT peer-to-peer protocols
and that architecture maybe do you two
want to chime in a bit on what was just
discussed I love hearing your thoughts
about things along the way yeah um
I think what's so beautiful about this
unfolding is that we the North planetary
Alliance is mando modeling what this
balanced architecture looks like because
we not only have the structural elements
but we're also creating the flow that
moves through those structures and for
me that flow is this is part of this
cultural shift and the way that we're
gonna shift humanity's consciousness and
awareness to be able to participate in
collaborative non hierarchical
structures because so much is ingrained
in even our own bodies with fear around
scarcity around not having enough not
being loved and so Christopher and I are
come from filmmaking backgrounds and art
backgrounds and we make virtual reality
and so part of what we're contributing
to the Alliance is creating the kinds of
experiences that are going to be
necessary to help people move through
their own personal journey to be able to
engage with these bigger systems because
as as above so below is one of the these
other core principles that we see
reflected throughout the universe that
everything external is also contained
internally and so when we bring that
into our awareness you know we really
need to have both both these external
structures and then this internal
transformation work and so things like
Vipassana things like the the 10-day
meditation courses which was a huge
turning point for me personally also we
want to find ways to use these
exponential technologies to create
similar kinds of experiences for people
that can scale for people who might not
be at a place yet where they're gonna
take that dive the first thing that
anyone ever says to me when I suggest
that they should do a 10-day retreat
it's like oh I can never do that and
what can you do two minutes yeah exactly
so can we give people the tools to do
that kind of work so that we can all
come together in new ways from that
place within ourselves and and outside
of ourselves I like that the flows and
the frameworks so you said the other
frameworks that are built out and the
flows of the resources through them and
then also you guys are gonna be doing
the journey for everyone helping make
this content material that helps people
and the
who they truly are into the world that's
that's beautiful yeah to just piggyback
on that a lot of what we see is that the
distribution of resources comes down to
this idea that there's winners and
losers and that therefore inside of our
society the wealth disparity is the
greatest it's ever been in history and
it's only going to increase with
automation until we have a different set
of systems that actually create
different incentives by which everyone
can be have their basic needs taken care
of which means they can care about other
things than just the scarcity of today
and when that happens that unleashes
much more of this potential it moves
from egocentric to ultimately ideally a
global centric of like how is humanity
are we crafting and co-creating a future
and what does that look like why is that
important well it's important because of
a lot of reasons other than we're
destroying our future currently and many
believe that well technology will come
in and save the day and it's like tech
is not a savior
we're the ones creating the tech it's
only a mirror of us but just bringing it
back to the resource flow of its when we
get beyond our own need for resources
for ourselves and our direct family that
we come to start to understand how we
can create a better experience for all
because this is no longer tried V tribe
it's not that is not the needed aspect
of surviving and so as we can come into
that and realize oh we're while we each
have our own individual belief
structures our own individual cultures
that that can live and continue on while
also being part of a greater whole and
that's one of the aspects that we really
focus on is how do we create those
stories and experiences along with the
protocol so that they're all supporting
each other and not disparate pieces that
are in silos there was a when you guys
were talking to me yes yesterday two
days ago now and teaching me
about the about the experience of taking
people to the from earth to the overview
effect of earth and then going back into
a specific experience on earth I love
hearing about things like this because
again you're really taking people to a
place where they can see the wholeness
of Earth and the community that is earth
and that it isn't just me and my family
but it's me my family my community the
country the continent and the entire
world as one as we move through the
cosmos and then as you started speaking
you went on the zero sum game and I love
talking about that I was a big part of
the TEDx talk in San Francisco last
month that I gave because if we view
things in a scarcity mindset of zero sum
of things like attention that it ends up
catalyzing a competition of winners and
losers versus the understanding of
unlocking the abundance that we have
that we can go out of this room and get
even further and more and love yeah
there's so much there let's go into
frameworks and protocols and I would
like to talk about how you guys are
putting together those frameworks what
that looks like and what are the
protocols that enable the resource flow
yeah so I'd also like to bridge in what
they were speaking around and how we
have the the structure which is more of
the masculine and then the flow which is
more of the feminine and then how sue me
out to see the world and coming back in
really puts into perspective of the
whole systems design lens right and
that's really what's needed is for
people to feel autonomous and embodied
in their individualism but also a part
of the whole and so that's a part of the
application development with the
protocols is how do we how do we really
bring that intrinsic wholeness state of
being back to the forefront of people's
reality
and yeah the structure and the protocols
what was your question let's go through
step into that you know how are you
laying out the frameworks and how is the
resource flow going to work through
those right so living systems principles
of being dynamic and fluid and intuitive
and adaptive and resilient and how do we
how do we take that and build it into a
system where we can cooperate at scale
which is what I keep pulling through
because this is really what's at hand
here I mean we've got everything that we
need on the planet at this time but we
just need to be able to cooperate at
scale and so what that actually looks
like is people being able to come into
the system and choose what sovereign
governance model they want to use as
well as what economic model they want to
use and so what we've done is we have
looked at all the sovereign governance
models out there today that are actually
working within ecosystems we've also
looked at all the different regenerative
economic models out there and really
looked at how we can create the
applications and the API for these
different models to actually be able to
communicate at a fundamental layer and
through that inquiry we've come to
peer-to-peer protocols which mimic
living systems and that is going to
allow us to operate across silos and
this is going to be absolutely
game-changing and a little bit more
context of what that actually looks like
and a cooperative ecosystem of many
different organizations and many
different creative minds coming together
as human beings not attached to
technology not a touch to brands but
coming in as individual creative
expressions of source ready to co-create
with each other and that framework looks
a little something as adaptable and
resilient as many different even old
world economic models bridge economic
models and future economic models
working together there was a really
profound quote in what you sent me in
the writing it was actually a part of
the writing was Conway's law Conway's
law says any organization that designs a
system defined broadly will produce a
design whose structure is a copy of the
organisation's communication structure
super well said so the better that's the
frameworks and flows are designed the
better the outcomes absolutely and you
know kind of I'm part of my work is
really looking at the meta architecture
and then extracting it all the way down
to the to the from the as above so below
and one of those one of those core
facets that always keeps coming back is
distribution and signaling of
communication and so even when you look
at diseases of like cancer and such when
you really look at at a at a biological
and cellular level it's it's really the
the flow of energy as being stopped and
it becomes incoherent and now the cells
are not communicating and now you have
cancer right and so that's what's
happening on our planet is we need to
just open up the barriers of
communication open up the barriers of
how these resources can be distributed
so we can begin to remove the cancer of
the planet and this is just super
critical and how does that happen what
is what does it look like for peer to
peer it's literally membrane to
membranes so every single node and the
ecosystem from one node to another right
so from one being to another there
membrane there now from one being to a
project there's also another membrane
there and so every single interconnected
point has a membrane with the other
point and this is where we can really
begin to work with the precision of the
distribution of communication and
resources think you thinking about it as
like a collection of nodes which are
these individuals or these projects that
were building and then the membrane
being how to communicate between to that
node actually get to that node
what is that communication now real
quick what was the study of the
government's and the regenerative
economy is that you mapped out and then
what did you figure out from that that
is going to be your a way to get through
these membranes and to make the
protocols like what did you figure out
from all that yeah so I figured out that
through the gut so it's a bit different
obviously between the governance and the
economy around the governance when I
look deeper into it is actually
different levels of consciousness we're
using different governance models and so
we want we obviously have different
levels of consciousness on the planet
and so different beings and ecosystems
will will choose depending on their
level of consciousness but since we're
in an evolving time very rapidly the
system needs to be able to co-evolved
with the consciousness and and create
you know more adaptability and so that's
been the biggest thing with with
governance and that when we looked at it
from a peer-to-peer perspective we we
saw that actually all the other
governance models were more deeper
frameworks for people who needed more
structure the less structure you need
the more that you don't have to go
through so much processing to
bureaucracy and red tape everything that
holds back innovation
and then to this really beautiful place
3 million page tax codes or whatever it
is right it's it's yeah it's really it's
really wild just how how in-depth I mean
just even you know holacracy which is a
really amazing one there's thousands of
organizations working with this platform
but it is like there's a lot of
structure to it and for me I'm just like
wow it takes all that to come to a
decision
you know and so when you break down
having to use this level of structure
you really start beginning to work with
the mechanics of the laws of creation
and it's really more around vibrational
law and frequency and and how how that
works so now that you're aware of
peer-to-peer protocols we now need the
the infrastructure that also mimics
nature in the digital environment to be
able to work with those protocols and be
able to scale them so we've been working
with some pioneers and digital
technology architectures and we are
building whole onic architectures for
this to begin self-organizing into and
what does that mean this means that it
is infinitely replicatable and
infinitely scalable and the backend of
it is using geometry to do this
infinitely repeatable infinitely
scalable Anthony infinitely replicatable
and infinitely scalable and also
self-healing so as nodes began to break
off and not work with one another it
just creates another geometry and that's
what's going to enable the communities
to speak these notes to speak through
the membranes yeah because it's so
evolving and you know there could be
three nodes at will at one point
communicating there could be 300 nodes
communicating and how that how that all
needs to be extremely adaptable and
able to continue to to evolve and the
biggest thing around this is like if
this is the very fabric of existence
from atoms to galaxies we might want to
start utilizing and integrating that
intelligence across all skills from
digital to social to ecological is that
then that all the communications are are
infinitely replicable is that what this
is that what this means that there's
like multiple Ledger's of this yes yeah
okay just to clarify a little bit for
those who aren't familiar with hellenic
architecture essentially it's a fractal
patterning of decentralized non
hierarchical collaborative systems so
think of them as these these membranes
these circles within circles connected
so you have nodes that are all playing
different functions within the system
and no one node is in a hierarchical
position above another node and so
through the peer-to-peer protocols we
can create this ecosystem of
collaborative structure where we don't
need hierarchy and so the feminine
intelligence accelerator is one of these
initial hellenic systems that's
currently made up of these six entities
and twelve individuals who are modeling
the effectiveness of this kind of
structure so we're a non collaborative
we are a collaborative non hierarchical
ecosystem in that we share resources
with one another as our projects overlap
we're able to bring each other in into
those membranes as appropriate and what
we're modeling through the feminine
intelligence accelerator is that the
value created in this system is
exponential that when we remove the
barriers that competition creates we're
actually creating the Opera
for value to accelerate and so we're
gonna model that through this initial
prototype so that we have a use case
that anyone in the world can look at and
see you know even just from an old-world
wealth generation perspective we're
still out we're going to be
outperforming these hierarchical
competitive systems so a couple things
first is I really enjoyed reading over
some of the material that you have
already created the idea of these like
things like this inclusive design
protocol you actually go through is this
needed every single time you design
something into the world no but is it a
general framework that is less than a
couple pages long that helps people go
through this process of discussing ideas
designing the ideas deciding on those
ideas and then reviewing how it went yes
and that's incredible and just to have
this down as a process that can go into
different areas so that so these are the
types of protocols these types of
systems that are going to go through the
framework and again the framework will
enable these communities to work
together an individual store together
yeah yeah and then I want to go over
there definitely so I just want to say
one thing about the inclusive design
process this is one process of a few
different blueprints that we're working
with a peer to peer level right so we
have minimal structure I like to call it
enlightened structure and no we don't
use these every time we we come into
deep resonance and deep alignment and
deep coherence and that's more of the
alchemy that we use to come into
decision making so literally our
structure is three steps how aligned are
me how aligned are we how much resonance
do we have in the container and how much
coherence do we have in the container so
we move from that space and anytime that
we feel tension we're not coming into
agreement on things we look at it as
creative tension instead of something is
wrong and so at that time we'll try to
work through the process and if we feel
that we need to bring in some some
structure we will go to a few of the
different inclusive design frameworks
that we have you beautifully said now
may I have some thoughts on the last
part from you guys about frameworks
flows the protocols I think an important
aspect of tying these pieces together
both from the aspect of the laws of
nature of like as below so above and
also designing these protocols and the
quote that you spoke to is ontological
design is this aspect of the things that
we design design us so until what we
really stand for is that the internal
world that we create for ourselves first
is the most important aspect because
that's what allows us to know that what
we're going to create is going to be
amazing for everyone as well as for
ourselves and so by doing the internal
work of destructuring our own mental
models and understanding how we're
perceiving the world were then able to
design from that aspect to allow for
others that possibility of freedom and
awareness around the way that they show
up in the world yeah I think there's a
woman named Bonita Roy who is a really
incredible meta modern thinker and she
describes this creative processes
whenever there is a tension or something
that's out of alignment listen to what
the other person is saying is though it
was your own voice and these are really
simple tools that can really bring us
into a state of coherence where the the
conflict is actually just adding a
dynamic perspective that it really
enriches our ability to understand
things more fully and so when we it's
very important it takes a lot of I mean
I've spent a lot of my life working to
get to a place where I am able to
deconstruct and reconstruct my mental
map of the universe more
quickly and effectively but when we only
have access to that technology of our
own creation and we can come into a
state of coherence with community and so
that's that's part of what with the
tools that we're creating are
experiences that bring people into that
state of sort of non-dual consciousness
or non-local consciousness where I
realized that I actually am not separate
from you and and when we can operate
from that place that's what gets me
really excited yeah now yeah I mean one
aspect that I think you just really
spoke to is this aspect of so often we
fall into this world of oh you're
different so we just want different
things
so like the outcome that we're trying to
go for like I'm going for something
different because I'm different than you
and therefore we have an impassable
conflict rather than this nature of like
Oh based on the incentives and the
belief structures that you have you're
looking at this from a different lens
let me try on that lens let me see how I
can step into that lens and you do the
same for me so that we can see where is
the miscommunication occurring that we
can actually then sit there speak to
that and then digest it and be like okay
we do have different outputs that we
want what is the most important output
from this interaction that we can create
and then that way there steps forward
rather than this impassable conflict of
no I want my way you want your way we're
different and that's the end of it so
the impassable conflict yeah how many
times do we see that we also made that
extremely prevalent in the talk that I
gave it today
the binary trap that we get into and
then also the ridiculousness of thinking
that we have the truth when we only have
our
but then when you wear all the other
lenses possible you have a better
understanding of the truth and they
don't become impassable they become
passable they become moving forward I
wanna I want it I want to actually get a
little bit I want to give an example so
will you give us an example of what will
happen once the infrastructure is in
place the frameworks and flows
yeah give us the example yeah that's
actually what I wanted to speak on this
so what does that look like for everyone
else once we start rolling out the
system and the infrastructure it's it's
gonna look like well it's going to be
gamified and it's going to be integrated
with the participatory what we call
participatory action platform so think
about if for instance many people are
aware of guy MTV which is really pushing
conscious evolution and have just you
know all walks of consciousness can go
there and explore enlightenment and one
thing that's missing is where can people
plug in and be interconnected with that
information and so that'll be a huge
part of the integrated platform the
enterable platform where people will be
able to come on and learn and be able to
choose how they want to experience it so
yes we are developing these
meta-narratives and AR and VR and mix
reality but that doesn't mean that
that's how you have to choose your
experience so we're really looking at
all levels of participation and all
walks of consciousness we'll choose many
different ways of how they want to plug
in and so that's a really really
important part if we're gonna be able to
open this up to all hearts and all minds
of the planet and it will be tied in of
course with the the governance and the
economy and you may say well how do how
do people who are not so enlightened or
not working with higher levels of
consciousness be able to
understand you know inclusive design
processes and governance and economy and
we have leading experts that will be
working with us to bring that forth into
the gamification and user experience
part of this so then you go for there's
some really interesting things that
happen with value flows when these kinds
of hellenic systems come online is when
you have these self-organizing
structures that are participation based
so if you think about in terms of cells
in the body you know I might come to the
realization I'm a heart cell so I'm
gonna get together with some other heart
cells and I have my membrane around me
but then I'm part of this greater
membrane that is the heart and we have a
function and within that context we can
create our own self-organized forms of
value flow so we can the heartbeat yeah
exactly and different ways of sending
signal different ways of sending signal
internally and externally and so one of
the things that I love to think about is
something that amber introduced into the
idea of tokenizing gratitude that we can
actually create our own currencies that
allow us to see the flow the currents of
these value exchanges in ways that are
multi-dimensional and monetary currency
is a single dimension it's a way of
exchanging value that you know is really
is a sandwich worth the same amount as a
backrub like how are those values
correlated because they're so
experiential and so personal and so as
we create these systems that are
self-organizing and we can create our
own value flows within those systems
we're going to be able to much more
effectively move value and really see
what is valuable to our communities and
that that's a concrete example to me of
how these different ways of visualizing
value will create that
more effective forms of exchange so and
what does what will it look like when
someone comes online to your
infrastructure so yes we have these
experiences that on board people into
the into the most really profound senses
of unlocking their full potential and
consciousness and contribution but then
what actually occurs when you know you
were me in this example of okay I am a
heart cell and within the heart
community so you are a cell within San
Francisco or London or Hong Kong where
you're at and then so how do they begin
to use the peer-to-peer protocols with
other people in Hong Kong how do they
work with San Francisco etc tell us
about how they would use though yeah so
there's there's gonna be pluggable
pluggable protocols so everything that
we're working on the back end that is
you know hyper complex where because we
are working with as above so below
principles and and many others it's
really going to show up for the user
experience and and the most simple way
you can imagine so that that's a part of
the intelligent design behind this and
people may say well gamified well not
everyone wants things gamified well just
even taking the agent centric
gamification design principles and
integrating them into applications just
as as your phone you know we can really
begin to utilize it and in that way as
well so let's go through an example if
I'm in San Francisco I want to become
part of north planetary alliance I want
to start working with the community on a
project through your platform and then I
want to see what other people across the
world are also building in their
communities how would that communication
work yeah so I think I need to bridge
through at this time that new earth
Planetary Alliance is really a steward
of these protocols and and codes and is
also architect helping to architect and
develop an engineer not only the
protocols but also the information
architectures and data structures
for the system and this system is not
new earth planetary alliances we are
stewards of weaving this together and
orchestrating the facets and so then
other people are within the community
are building out the protocols that will
then open up so Hong Kong may make its
own open source protocol and San
Francisco may make its own open source
PDP protocol and yes so the thing with
p2p protocols is that you literally can
scale it from an individual to a nation
right so these protocols work at all
scales that really goes back to how
adaptable and resilient these protocols
are and what what we're actually working
on is more of like a global how the
global nervous system of intelligence
will work so we have many other eco
systems working on many other parts of
this and how that might look for you
know people across the world to plug in
to the new system is through semantic
coordination of the data and the
evolving fields of collective
intelligence through a cognitive
assistant and so I feel that that's more
along the lines of of how this
information will move across silos so
tell us about the cognitive assistance
yeah so the cognitive assistant this is
really something that we've been we've
been looking at deeply as well as how
can we distribute information and
resources more quickly I sort of say at
a quantum quantum rate but also and so
utilizing exponential tech like
artificial intelligence but really
infusing it with biomimetic protocols so
that way the technology is there just to
help us orient and it's not there to
take over our lives or make decisions
for us and so utilizing the quantum
capabilities of artificial intelligence
infused with biomimetic protocols will
pretty much you know bring everything
that we need right to
right to our phones so the cognitive
assistant enables me to more easily do
what I need with in my life the
community the world yeah so it'll
aggregate the information based on what
you're inquiring about so whatever you
need or won or desire it's going to
bring you those people places and
resources and it's gonna bring them to
you in a very intelligent way so you can
further and quire deeper where you might
want to plug in with those pieces and
then looking for the cognitive assistant
works with the different hubs across the
world whatever protocols they have
written yeah and then these are your
basic aliy working working with what we
call associative networks so that could
be an individual known as an individual
agent in the system which that
individual agent has data around what
they're doing and what they have and
where they're going right and then also
the group agents as well and so each of
these are associative networks and
through them through the peer-to-peer
protocols the associative networks can
communicate at the fundamental layer to
scale across silos right and so this is
a really really important facet that
when we begin to scale fields of super
intelligence so to say fields of deep
neural networks right that actually when
we talk about transforming the planet at
some point these networks will need to
communicate at some level and we're able
to do that through these peer-to-peer
protocols where we'll be able to come
into a unified conceptual space and the
digital realm or otherwise known as a
unified space memory network and that
will allow us to aggregate information
from many different associative networks
creating a truly decentralized
peer-to-peer
distributed planetary operation system
love it I love that and that does move
us away from silos which it looks like
everything is moving away from that
towards what you just described
now mmm will everybody have their own
cognitive assistant yes as they choose
right so some people may not choose to
do so but they're you know then whatever
they have ax access to will be obviously
much different so but it is it is our
goal to provide this level of technology
to to all the continents so what that
might look like is we really are looking
at it once again as a whole systems
design approach so therefore we're not
just looking at technology innovation
and you know AR and VR and gamification
we're also looking at it from the
permaculture side of things and and
built environments and urban redesign
and also you know countries that that
don't have the resources and how can we
get them the resources and in a very
quick way and so we do have plans to
even drop ship shipping containers would
distribute attack including 3d printers
that can print villages in a matter of a
week you know farm in a box water water
purification systems and and so we are
planning to really drop into a planetary
operations yeah yeah that that's really
interesting how there's a lot of
different partners involved with that
are all building the future in these
different ways and they all want to
decentralize what they're doing and they
all want to be a part of a network like
this and that's good ok so thoughts from
me too yeah I mean the immediate thing
that just came up for me inside of what
we're speaking about is everyone thinks
it's the muscles that move the body
like and to me the muscles in our system
that we're looking at it from are the
silos and it's actually the way that the
muscles connect to the bones and it's
the connective tissue throughout your
body that is some of the most important
tissues in your body because none of it
can work without those connective
tissues and so that's really what we're
speaking about is how do all of these
different pieces connect because we all
want to be doing things in an integrated
way yet for most of the time especially
when we are masculine driven we come
head to head and when we're coming head
to head were not connecting and I think
something from before that we were
speaking to around the feminine aspects
of this is that when you you know
there's been studies shown that when you
empower women in you know in poverty
situations what happens versus when you
empower men when you empower men they
make money for themselves put food on
the table for their family and then go
spend whatever money they have when you
empower women they actually bring up the
whole community they actually are set up
to like the way that they care is beyond
just their immediate nature of like
right here inside of this pod and I
think that that is one of the aspects of
feminine intelligence that we really
look to bring into both technologies and
also these protocols of how do we how
are we connecting together rather than
how are we you know as you spoke to like
the zero-sum game how are we winning
versus at all costs in just add to that
I think there can be this gut reaction
to hearing something like that it's
various points in my life would have
reacted to feeling like the the
masculine is
being vilified in this moment that and
yet that couldn't be further from the
truth that as we come into balance
internally at least I would just speak
for myself as I have allowed my own
feminine to flourish and to not be
shamed my masculine has actually gotten
even stronger and really learning what
what are the what isn't enlightened
masculine what is what is a healed and
whole masculine energy and what kind of
contributions does that energy have to
have to bring to the whole and so I did
not just Center it on the mask gun
because I think we are moving in its
we're rebalancing the system and we've
been in this very imbalanced masculine
phase for a long time so it's like we're
no need to go there but I do think just
for any men listening it's not that you
are wrong it's not that there's anything
wrong with masculinity except that it's
out of balance and when we come back
into balance the characteristics of the
masculine that really can contribute to
this planetary awakening are being our
holding are creating semipermeable
boundaries that are not rigid but are
flexible and being able to be strong
while being flexible so that we don't
create these rigid systems that you know
we can feel it in our own bodies you
know I
we all carry that tension with us of
living in a society that's this out of
balance and so how do we how do we find
that flow state where where we can hold
effectively well being flexible and
allowing things to inhale and exhale
expand and contract these are these are
these core principles inhalation and
exhalation is another one of these chord
natural principles that everything is
constantly inhaling and exhaling and and
so we don't need to fight that we can we
just like move into a space of allowing
yes so I'd really like to touch base on
allowing and how important that is for
all of us and it really comes through as
one of the feminine intelligence
principles of receptivity and you would
not you would be so surprised how many
people are willing to give and take but
actually do not know how to receive and
that is a part of the heart and how it
speaks and interacts and so really
bridging that through at this time and
and the receptivity is just super super
key for catalyzing transformation so
just tell us a little bit more about
that giving and taking that's become
quite easy throughout society but what
is this allowing that you speak of
allowing yes so there's there's
different levels of allowing and
receiving just like I've come to find
different levels of presenting and the
more you can be open to receive the the
better the better tools you'll have to
navigate this can be like we were
talking about earlier if you can receive
someone's and glens that they see the
world with you will have a more true
lens of the way you see the world yeah
absolutely
and so personally coming from so much
fire and so much information and just
wanting to like you know get it out and
share with people and be like oh my god
this is like so amazing geez you guys
understand what's happening and and then
realizing that people weren't able to
really receive it because I was just
talking to so many different walks of
consciousness and I began to understand
that it was better for me to first
enquire to the field and see where they
were at and then respond and so that was
a huge part of really being able to
receive the people that were in front of
me first before I just tried to
distribute any information and that
that's been a huge part of more people
being able to receive what's coming
through because it is a very different
way of feeling and thinking and being
than what this planet is used to so as
we go forth and change the social
context that we live in with these
frameworks and these flows and new earth
planetary alliance
I am very looking forward to what comes
up how do people end up working together
with you well we do have membranes that
we are creating we're getting ready to
model the first prototype through an
accelerator that is called the feminine
intelligence accelerator and there's six
different components of that accelerator
but I think I'll move back into playing
with new earth planetary alliance and
that'll kind of bridge in yeah both both
contexts so people can get in contact
with us through we are nepo
at gmail.com and in the coming months
we'll be opening up a public
communications channel where many people
can come through and start to interact
with with the council and other people
who are inspired to co-create with us
awesome that link is in the bio that
emails in the bio okay great so that is
really looking forward to people
reaching out and also the communications
channel opening up to co-creating build
the future I think what we're hoping to
do now is create a model by which other
people can take it and and run with it
and so in the near future as these
systems come online they'll really just
be a template where if someone wants to
get involved and create their own
accelerator we will have all the
protocols in place where you can take
that entire toolkit and adapt it to your
community your passion whatever it is
that you're here on this planet to
create you'll be able to use these tools
so
yeah tell us about that website yes so
the feminine intelligence also has a
website it's currently being updated and
you'll be able to go there to see the
development of this prototype will also
be where you are Fi
we are the Phi comm we are the final and
we're looking to open a feminine
intelligence headquarters and spring and
Venice California and this is where we
will be doing testings of these
protocols with exponential technology
and the meta-narratives so the
accelerator is around transformational
media and TAC and how we can start
utilizing this new cooperative
ecosystemic framework with the yeah
evolution that that's that's coming
through and ready to shift the planet
and we we really are seeing this as a
safe space for other innovators and
pioneers working in this field to have a
space that they can come and play with
with this level of knowledge and energy
okay let's wrap up by saying thank you
thank you for coming out of the show
thank you for talking to us this has
been a pleasure thank you thank you
thank you yeah I feel very blessed to be
with you all and that what you're
building is extremely important and keep
building keep building keep building we
need you we need you we need you and I'm
glad that we started unpacking this is
just you know interview number one on
all this subject so we have a lot more
to talk about as it keeps unfolding will
continue doing media content about it
pushing that out there so be ready
because the next time there will be more
created there will be more to talk about
and thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it please
exactly so we have a depth of demo
coming up there's so much to showcase
and talk about and unpack really looking
forward to another one soon another
conversation soon and leave us your
thoughts in the comments we'd love to
hear from you love to hear from you and
all that we talked about so give us your
thoughts go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
much love this has been going great by
the way great job everyone
yeah very job yeah yeah this has been
fantastic
great work yeah I knew it's gonna go
great nothing nothing not nothing that I
interview ever goes bad we'll see yeah
it's like the surgeon that's never had
someone die or whatever the hostage
negotiator that's never lost or whatever
yeah we'll see yeah exactly yeah
eventually we'll lose whoa this storm
out there like you're to a quantumness
I'm out of here yeah yeah I can tell how
much time this is gonna take me to edit
yeah yeah it makes us look skinny here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]